comme avec la communauté
des États-Unis,
je m'appelle Jerry Dealey. Je vis ici à
Dallas. Je suis né ici
.
mes concitoyens américains ne demandent pas ce que votre
pays peut faire pour vous demandez ce que vous pouvez
faire pour votre pays
je m'appelle cathlin Andrew Je suis
étudiant en finance à la Southern Methodist University
de Houston au Texas et ce que JFK signifie pour
moi c'est qu'il est un peu le cas  étude sur le
charisme et la politique et comment la
personnalité joue un rôle énorme dans ce que nous
considérons comme service public
mon nom est Bruno je viens du sud de l'
Allemagne et cet endroit est très important
pour l'Allemagne parce que John F Kennedy était un
président célèbre aussi des Allemands de la forêt je
veux dire il  avait un discours et Berlin et il est
très célèbre en Allemagne il parlait il a
besoin du mur de Berlin
vous savez est un leader il parlait
allemand aussi il a dit ich bin ein Berliner
et c'était très important pour le
président vous kn  maintenant je vais Ashley Park,
je viens de Coppell Texas et je suis en
deuxième année d'études en comptabilité
à la Cox School of Business JFK est
toujours un très gros point d'interrogation pour moi et
j'espère que notre génération
pourra résoudre ce mystère qui a affecté
tant de gens dans le passé,
des coups forts viennent facilement au-dessus de ma
tête, la
Styrie étant complètement encordée par
Donald